andré bercoff merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors attaqué
assailli par les kings est ce qu'on peut
dire que les cinq candidats d'hier se
sont un peu ligués contre michael
bloomberg lors du débat télévisé écouter
à partir du moment où les milliards de
dollars en prêts dans la danse les
autres il fallait bien qu'il parce
qu'ils ont peur effectivement l'argent
quand même jouent un rôle non
négligeable pas seulement aux états unis
mais surtout aux etats-unis c'est quand
même très exemplaire et alors ils se
sont dit bloomberg qui je le rappelle
pèse 70 milliards de dollars
c'est à dire au moins au moins dix fois
plus que trump
donc ils se sont dit ouh là là il peut
faire beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
choses
voilà je dois dire d'ailleurs j'ai
regardé une bonne partie du débat je
veux dire que elizabeth warren a été
très forte
les deux minutes où elle a parlé du fait
de sa bd de ces contrats d'ultra
confidentialité après avoir soi disant
je ne je n'en sais rien harcelée soit
enfin harceler des femmes soit
sexuellement soit par une espèce de
harcèlement moral et cetera génère que
bloomberg moi ce qui m'a étonné dans
cette histoire c'est que bloomberg
dépensent des centaines de millions de
dollars mais il a pas un coach il devait
savoir qu'on allait lui poser des
questions
légèrement embarrassante c'était évident
ce qui ce qui m'a étonné lors se veut
pas dire que les choses sont jouées
c'est que ses réponses devant les
questions face aux questions de ses
adversaires étaient franchement assez
allez on va être poli et gentil assez
simpliste et simple est ça m'a étonné
quelqu'un comme lui dans les tic il ya
les moyens de se préparer je les
trouvais en partie en difficulté
absolument mais en partie ne répondant
pas à une attaque un pas comme il
fallait à ces questions là parce
qu'évidemment il était attendu au
tournant sur ce question soit de
richesse soit mais vous allez acheter
les élections vous êtes là pour ça parti
démocrate n'est pas le parti
de la finance etc etc je trouve qu'il
n'a pas été à la hauteur de ce qu'on
pouvait attendre de quelqu'un qui a
effectivement l'argent qu'il a qui a
réussit admirablement faut le dire en
tant que businessman et en tant que
maire de new york qui n'a pas démérité
alors arrogant raciste c'est un peu en
substance ce qui lui a été reproché hier
est ce que vous contrôlez ces critiques
alors écoutez arrogant et raciste ce
sont évidemment des caricatures que lens
tous les bons professionnels de la
politique
trump a été traité dix fois pire très
peu racistes xénophobes homophobes et
c'est ça pour moi c'est la menue monnaie
de la politique assure joël comment dire
l'amérique
le vrai problème il n'est pas là c'est
qu'il ne s'est pas montré encore une
fois à la hauteur de 2 de répondre de
façon claire et forte et de contre
attaquer je les trouvais comme ça
vraiment alors ça veut pas dire que les
les cartes que les jeux sont
faits bien sûr loin de là ce qui va être
très intéressant ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui il ya vraiment c'est très
intéressant
il y a les deux extrêmes il y a le
milliardaire bloomberg le entre
guillemets socialiste sander ce parce
que en amérique on l'appelle socialiste
où tous ceux qui sont à la gauche de la
social démocratie et entre les deux il y
abouti gyan et byden qui essaye de se
disputer les voix des modérés
ça veut dire trois choses ça veut dire
que primo vraiment le parti démocrate
est extrêmement écartelée la deuxième
chose c'est de savoir est ce que c'est
un des extrêmes en b extrême
howe on y voit la laune américaine qui
va gagner
et troisièmement est ce que les
centristes tout aussi redit mais vont le
faire
moi je crois en tout cas que si je t'ai
tonale trup je serais assez souriant
aujourd'hui selon vous il n'y a aucun
candidat démocrate capable en tout cas
de faire trembler donald trump
ça je n'en sais rien aujourd'hui
si on regarde ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui à mon avis ils sont assez
mal barré mais vous savez toutes les
surprises sont possibles
on ne va pas faire de jeu j'aime pas les
pronostics et j'aime encore moins les
voyantes
donc je crois qu'on ne peut pas
absolument pas préjuger de ce qui va se
passer surtout avant le super tuesday
c'est le fameux super tuesday le super
mardi qu'ils valent et terminer les
choses mais dans tout est possible mais
je crois qu'aujourd'hui ce qui était
d'ailleurs frappant c'étaient les images
du grand meeting de donald trump et de
cet affrontement quand même assez
violent c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
entre les nominés et les candidats du
parti démocrate
ce sont des images qui a même qui vont
rester andré bercoff merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes éditorialistes et auteur du
livre donald trump les raisons de la
colère publié aux éditions first merci